quand on m'a téléphoné pour participer à
ces x j'ai tout de suite dit oui mais
j'étais super content ça faisait
quelques années que je disais que je
voulais me prêter à cet exercice avant
mes 30 ans et ça tombe bien j'ai 30 ans
le mois prochain
c'est que quand j'ai raccroché le
téléphone
que je me suis rendu compte que j'allais
devoir parler devant 300 personnes
et là je peux vous dire j'ai commencé à
avoir un petit peu peur être un petit
peu inquiet en plus personne n'avait dit
que j'allais être le premier
mais pourquoi est-ce que je suis ici
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai tout de suite
dit oui je me suis posé cette question
j'ai tout de suite dit oui parce que je
crois que je suis quelqu'un d'impulsif
un homme de défis et qui est plein de
curiosité
j'ai envie de me laisser croire que je
peux être toujours ce petit garçon qui
croient que les rêves ça se réalise
bon avec le temps j'ai appris pour
réaliser ses rêves il fallait quand même
beaucoup travaillent
justement quand j'étais ce petit garçon
j'ai grandi dans la broye fribourgeoise
dans une maison avec un immense jardin
botanique de 850 espèces de plantes
différentes
ma soeur et moi on a eu une éducation
proche de la nature proche de la terre
mes parents nous ont toujours montré
comment consommer ce que nos jardins
pouvaient produire à l'école durant les
récrés on se faisait parfois un peu
moqué parce qu'on mangeait nos petites
graines de courge et nos petites graines
de tournesol alors quelque part manger
des tweaks et dès mars on nous disait
c'est les petits moineaux de la famille
fontaine ils mangent des galettes
quand j'étais ce petit garçon j'étais
quelqu'un t'a déjà très curieux très
actif tout le monde dit à mes parents
quelle belle qualité avec la curiosité
oh le petit nicolas comme il est actif
c'est génial
c'était génial jusqu'à ce que je
commence l'école obligatoire
durant mes premières années d'école
obligatoire ça a été assez compliqué de
rentrer dans le cadre de rentrer dans le
moule
j'ai rapidement été diagnostiquée
hyperactif
bien sûr ça a créé passablement de
problèmes avec mon comportement on me
disait j'ai été un élément perturbateur
on court un peu un sale gosse
je rentrais souvent la maison avec des
mots à faire signer par mes parents de
mes preuves la direction qui disait que
ça n'allait pas on me disait des fois à
l'école j'étais un quart perdu j'arrive
là rien
bien sûr ces tensions de l'école je les
ai aussi ramener à la maison
à la maison avec mes parents ça a été
très compliqué sur m6 profite ce soit
pour leur dire merci et leur patience
un jour j'ai même retrouvé la valise
avec mes affaires devant la porte et mes
parents qui me disais bon n'en peut plus
si tu continues c'est l'internât
heureusement dans un maul même beaucoup
j'ai pu rester à la maison
tout le monde pensait que j'allais faire
des études j'allais aller au collège et
malheureusement est arrivé ce qui devait
arriver je n'ai pas obtenu mon
certificat de fin d'année des études
j'ai dû aller faire un apprentissage
pour beaucoup de gens c'était un peu un
échec que j'irai faire un apprentissage
et maintenant avec le recul pour moi ça
a été la voie royale j'ai fait un
apprentissage de paysagiste c'était une
première confrontation avec le monde du
travail avec la dureté du chantier j'ai
pu aussi rencontrer d'autres adultes que
mes parents et des professeurs de
l'école
malgré tout j'avais quand même mes
problèmes
l'hyperactivité être comportement j'ai
changé d'entreprise et juste avant les
examens finaux j'ai tout voulu arrêter à
nouveau je peux dire merci à mes parents
qui ont fait tout ce qu'ils ont pu pour
que j'obtienne mon cfc j'avais un chef
c'est super je savais pas ce que je
voulais faire
j'avais plein d'idées je voulais faire
plein de changer tes voyages été
travaillé à droite à gauche mais s'était
jamais le bon moment j'avais pas
forcément de l'argent vous réaliser mes
idées et surtout ça manquait de cadres
justement parlons cadre est arrivé le
moment où j'ai dû aller à l'armée
à l'art mais tu peux vous dire que le
cadre c'est une condition sinequanone
pour que ça se passe bien l'autorité
faut la respecter plus j'avais été
sélectionnée pour faire grenadiers
parachutistes ahizoune
mon lieutenant il était pas autant cool
que ma maman
je me souviens encore de fontaine but
sommet de la montagne comportement lutte
directe retour chez fait des allers
retours
mais malgré tout cette expérience a
alarmé était pour moi une des
expériences les plus formatrices j'ai
appris à découvrir les limites de mon
corps limites de mon esprit j'ai appris
la camaraderie j'ai appris que ont passé
tous ensemble la ligne d'arrivée qu'on
n'ait jamais laisser quelqu'un derrière
je pense que c'est de là que je tire
aussi cette énergie cette force de
toujours aller au bout des choses que
j'entreprends c'est aussi à ce moment là
de ma vie j'ai décidé d'accepter qui
j'étais de faire de mes faiblesses mes
forces
je me suis dit nico
de toute façon tu peux pas plaire à tout
le monde parce que plaire à tout le
monde ça serait permanent pour ce qui
est à ce moment là de ma vie ça a été
pour moi comme naître une deuxième fois
et cette deuxième vie elle a commencé en
2013 quand je suis arrivé on va aller au
ciel
je suis arrivé dans une colocation une
colocation que gère depuis maintenant
huit mois et qui m'a permis d'habiter
avec plus de 70 personnes différentes
cinq grandes maisons
des gens de tous horizons de tous
profils de tout âge
c'est ça qui a beaucoup inspiré les
choses que je fais aujourd'hui certains
de ces colloques sont encore des amis
des gens avec qui je travaille des gens
écrit je crée des projets j'arrive en
toi sur ma tête on arrive en valais
j'avais pas de travail
j'avais un ciel cette paysagiste
j'ai rapidement trouvé du travail à sia
dans une entreprise de la région mais
après une année je me suis rendu compte
que je voulais être maître de mon destin
professionnel que je voulais essayer
d'être mon propre patron
mais un nouveau j'avais un peu peur
j'avais quand même dans ma tête ces
phrases de l'époque qui me disait tu
n'arrivera à rien dans la vie nicolas
et c'est là que je me suis rendu compte
de l'importance des rencontres les gens
qui passent notre chemin
j'ai rencontré lionel qui était mon
premier associé qui était le premier à
me dire nico je crois en toi je crois en
nous pierrot lance une entreprise
paysagisme et on l'a fait et je peux
dire maintenant que je serai pas
l'entrepreneur que je suis aujourd'hui
si lionel en 2014 il m'avait pas dit
lionel à nico je crois en toi
en 2017 on avait besoin de diversifier
un petit peu nos activités durant
l'hiver les paysagistes en a pas
beaucoup de travail c'était pas facile
de nourrir tout le monde c'est là qu'on
s'est dit mais on va les y a plein de
barriques de vin qui traînent un peu
partout non plus est-ce qu'on ne serait
pas de faire quelque chose avec et c'est
comme ça qu'est née dionysien de nizas
heineken entreprise qui recycle des
vieilles barriques de vin on récupère un
petit peu les déchets des uns pourront
faire la richesse des autres on
revalorise ces vieux tonneaux ont beau
fauteuil en horloge
ont fait des tabous et
en 2017 c'est aussi le moment où grâce à
toutes les rencontres que j'ai eues
insert personnes un colloque le moment
on a eu l'idée de créer satellite
satellite c'est une association à but
non lucratif qui veut favoriser le vivre
ensemble la culture le social et
l'écologie en ville de sya
c'est un projet dans lequel j'ai trouvé
beaucoup de sens à ma vie s'articule
souvent si différents projets qui sont
des jardins communautaires qui sont de
la bande dessinée dans le journal de
sierre depuis peu dans la gazette de
martinez c'est un centre culturel et
social on retrouve une bibliothèque
d'objets des espaces d'exposition des
petits ateliers on a un fab lab où les
gens peuvent apprendre à travailler le
bois le métal les gens échangent et
savoir faire
on a même des moutons qu'on utilise pour
entretenir des zones des espaces verts
ont ville de sierre et dernièrement on a
fait un espace de travail partagé pour
des artistes et des créatifs
à travers cette association
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de gens qui
partagent partagent des valeurs communes
oman où le vivre ensemble
c'est un petit peu moins de biens plus
de liens on échange on partage
en 2018
hyperactivité la curiosité de ma
jeunesse leurs parents j'ai besoin de
changement de faire autre chose je suis
retourné vers lionel et je lui dis
j'aimerais arrêter le paysagisme
par chance on s'est très bien entendu il
rachetait mais par la société et à ce
moment là ma vie j'avais des personnes
autour de moi yanis garrett nikos qui
étaient des amis qui avaient envie de
créer comme moi les créatifs il ya eu ce
fameux atelier on a commencé dans un
garage il y avait de la pluie qui
tombait du plafond on n'a pas beaucoup
de sous et on voulait faire une
entreprise de robotique
un paysagiste un logisticien un mécano
est un artiste
c'était mal barré
on a commencé
passionné rêveur
on a trouvé un robot de deux tonnes en
allemagne
qu'on a commandé sur internet
et un matin ya ce robot qui arrivait
devant l'atelier
super
il répare les ingénieurs
et là on a commencé à se mettre au
travail j'ai la chance d'être entouré de
gens qui sont devenus des spécialistes
dans leur domaine
on a eu nos premières réussites
et nos premiers échecs bien sûr l'une de
ses réussites ça a été le projet robot
clette
avec le projet robot clette il ya aussi
des belles rencontres
emmanuel pigna qui est le deuxième papa
de buckley teddy ballif à lemaitre
racleurs ont tout de suite cru en cette
idée de créer un ambassadeur de
l'innovation et de la tradition la leon
un robot qui raque de leurs athlètes
depuis la foire du valais 2019 ça a été
un projet fou pour moi un des projets
les plus fous du mali on est passé de
martini rade vers matt à berne à las
vegas et dernièrement encore au maroc
avec nos demis meules de fromage et nos
robots
ça me fait sourire quand je tape sur
internet au maroc robot clac ya des
articles de presse menons sur le valais
l'innovation et la raclette
pour moi
voeckler a été aussi une immense
opportunité de crédibiliser notre
travail nous démontrer que c'est pas
parce qu'on n'avait pas d'ingénieur
qu'on pouvait pas faire c'est ses
projets et attendre un petit peu serré
fou après le repos clette on a cru au
workshop 4.0 une société qui veut
développer
l'intégration de robots les nouvelles
technologies pour le bien commun j'ai
envie de dire j'ai envie d'utiliser ces
machines
pour nous aider dans les différents
travaux pénibles qu'on a à faire
pourquoi pas même taxé et robots pour
financer le revenu de base
inconditionnel
on a vous le verrez tout à l'heure à
l'espace innovation la chance de mettre
la main sur un des robots les plus
évoluées de la planète le robot spot et
ça a été pour nous aussi une phénoménale
aventure ces exemples 1
c'est pour moi la preuve que qu'importe
d'où l'on vient
qu'importe notre parcours universitaire
qu'importe que on est de l'argent ou pas
c'est important de croire en nos rêves
faut se battre pour les réaliser c'est
pas forcément tout le temps facile - m
plus d'une fois j'ai voulu tout laisser
tomber même encore dernièrement avaient
recours tschopp on a eu des soucis et je
remettais tout en question mais en fait
du moment qu'on est bien entouré qu'on a
des gens sur qui on peut compter qu'ils
sont des gens qui sont les avocats de
l'orangé dont les avocats du démon
on peut réussir affable grandes choses
un jour j'ai entendu dans un film
l'histoire de deux petites souris qui
étaient tombés dans un seau de l'est
après un petit sourit elle a très vite
arrêté de se battre elle est morte noyée
la deuxième elle s'est battue elle a
transformé les encres et hamel a pu
sortir du sol et ce soir c'est ce que
j'ai envie de partager
soyez tous là deuxième ce courrier tout
le monde à la valeur et à des bonnes
idées
entourez-vous bien et ensemble je pense
qu'on peut réaliser de grandes choses
j'ai envie encore dire et de profiter de
l'opportunité qui m'a été donnée ce soir
de parler pour remercier tous les jours
on qui croyons les idées qui
m'accompagne un petit peu dans mes
folies car sans vous je serai pas
l'homme que je suis venu aujourd'hui
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]